who are you rooting for on all-stars
five fierce queens are back for their
Redemption I am very very excited to see
what shake you lay and the lair st.
Claire bring because they have won't
they have a nothing but time and money
to improve their drag so god knows it is
going to be good shake cool a is of
course like everything I want Alexis
Mateo to win so about you so freaking
funny to me just like someone who is
naturally just so charismatic like
killed every challenge on her season and
I'm glad that it's like she's in three
so some of the kids who haven't seen
that far back will be introduced to her
amazingness I think the one who needs
the most redemption because honey
America loves her down boots and you
already know it's Michelle a obviously
obviously but miss cracker and his
cracker is up there too baby I love this
where I love me some cracker but baby
shade is that [ __ ] always my mama boom
bring the Queen her child Hayabusas
luggage is home to the same mistakes we
made in hallway
Ongina really captured my heart in all
the way back in season one
my name is angina and from the very
first season of RuPaul's Drag Race
what she brings I am definitely here for
Miss shake who lay Aegina I'm happy IAD
Affairs back I was honestly scared and
all I could do was scream I think that
if anyone's going to be my frontrunner I
love miss Potter so much this cracker
taught me so much about my drag from the
beginning stages every single Sunday I
would go see Britta and then I would go
see Monet and cracker to a show together
keeping it in the New York City family I
want to see her as a woman of color I
gotta go for my girls Shea and Jujubee
they're amazing drag artists and I look
up to them so much you know also I
actually loved Blair st. Clair on her
season so I'm really excited to see what
she brings this this year and also my
good system is cracker like there's
there's so many and I would have to say
I mean it's an amazing cast but I would
have to say I am rooting for Miss shake
who lay all the way shape for the crown
only because she was the first girl that
liked to be around when I was conquer
the first time like four years ago and
before she was on drag race and she's
sweet her fashion is amazing and I just
feel like Shane brings something new I'm
the total package if you are placing
bets on anybody like
you want to throw $5 down on me I was
really shy so hard on her season so I
have to keep rooting for her but I'm
also Jujubee her interaction is with
Raven what what literally made me start
doing dry is that my ring is that yours
it is now [ __ ] jujubee's personality
was everything that inspired to do as a
baby track queen it just looks all of
the meat very much to me and so I am
rooting for Shay and I'd say my top
three are cracker Shay and Jujubee they
all represent like my favorites from
their respective seasons Jay is like so
beautiful and polished and she makes a
great show cracker is so funny and so
meticulously comedic and Jujubee is so
naturally charismatic that it's hard to
not root for her to miss Tyra was your
barbecue cancelled your grill is hard to
see Jujubee I I fell in love with her
all the way back on season 2 when she
was all and she's been with my favorite
Queens
ever since then for many many in years
10 years and to see her all the show is
amazing and also I met her in person
when I first started doing drag and I
told her I want to be on the show one
day and we had a little Kiki and I have
a little background story that to
embarrass it's a bug affair but yeah we
got to share that story at some point
what what in the what I'm so excited to
be able to watch a season of drag race
especially after I've been on a season I
want to watch this season to the best of
my ability without having a favorite
because now that I know how all the
challenges are and I know that there are
parts of the challenges that people
don't get to see that might you know
prevent someone from doing well or
succeeding I'm excited to see just the
drag that the girls bring rather than
like uh-oh you know shake cool eh didn't
do well in this challenge I thought
gonna do well and that's such a shame
it's an amazing roster overall you know
I think it's such a cool group we have a
lot of early season queens which I
watched the show since season one but so
many of the younger generation and the
new fanbase has it so this is exciting
it's exciting for this whole brand to
kind of celebrate its history a little
bit so I'm excited to see those early
season Queens and see what they bring
it's it's gonna be a fight to the finish
back my girls